hi everyone my name is keen brown mark
Hammond and I are the founders of a
startup called Banzai Banzai was founded
two three years ago now we our goal was
to vastly simplify and improve the
experience of programming with
artificial intelligence with a goal of
opening this technology up to as many
programmers as possible there's a
important fundamental insight behind how
we got here and that's that's the idea
of abstraction abstraction and an idea
that's its core to computer science and
we we see it over and over and over
again so we've seen it in the past when
we went from transistor to transistor
logic to using arithmetic logic units to
full-on CPUs we see it in say video
games and graphics when we move from
programming directly with assembly to
programming with frameworks and
libraries like OpenGL to full-on
scripting environments like unity where
you're not dealing with say low-level
polygon primitives instead you're
talking about these are the objects I
want to machine this is the kind of
physics so what I want in the
relationship between it it happens also
in data you know if you think think back
a long time ago when you program with
data you were you were focused on
lower-level data structures a binary
tree then we got libraries of these data
structures that simplified and improve
the process for us and eventually we had
programming languages like sequel and
sequel is really cool because you don't
have to worry about the the underlying
details of how that data is stored how
the query exactly runs now obviously you
can peer in and know about it if you
want to but it's not something that's
thrown directly in your faces of
programmer and even with new frameworks
like Dupin and SPARC today sequel of
course is still around as a way of
programming if we look at all these
changes in all these levels of
abstraction we notice a pattern in terms
of several benefits that appear every
time we abstract or we simplify the
biggest of which of course is that
problems you can solve and the things
you can do it increases in scope there's
more of them the the language is just
become more powerful and you can
do that in less time it with each of
these frameworks as we go up to stack
there's always new ways to reuse and
sharing so like if we if we think of the
the library case over time the reuse and
sharing of both the code and compiled
binary units it's become easier and
easier another important point from this
process of abstraction is that when the
abstraction is right it also aids and
simplifies the explained ability so it's
interesting because we don't always it's
not always even though it's great to say
look at assembly code that doesn't
always tell you exactly what a program
is doing right it's better often to look
at the higher level up lastly this idea
of future-proof when you upgrade a
database you don't have to rerun or
recompile your entire system instead you
just upgrade the database and then you
immediately get all the benefits all the
performance increases of that without
having to change your code at bonsai our
goal is to to bring some of this to AI
and when we looked across the market
today we sort of saw three approaches to
how people were programming with AI and
machine learning the most common of
which there's things like toolkits this
is your your h2o or your tensor flow
these these toolkits are great because
they give you incredible amounts of
control but they're not very explainable
and pretty much every time a new
algorithm comes out you have to throw
away the code you wrote and and write a
new model another group we call
statistical analysis packages these are
products ranging from say like our in a
certain sense or in particular data
robot this is where you feed a bunch of
data in or you you set up something in a
model can get generated for you and this
is great in that it's very easy to use
but it has the problem of once that
model is generated if you want to change
it you're right back into working
directly with a toolkit but now it's
much more complicated because the model
itself was machine generated API is
definitely hit a sweet spot here and
that I think they're the easiest to
program with but of course the problem
is is that they only do that specific
slice of functionality so if
you have as a simple problem that can be
solved by imagenet like tell me what
objects are on this table you're fine
but you know we've talked to customers
that are like I need can you tell me
when the when this board comes off the
line whether it has a tombstone
capacitor tombstone capacitors of course
are not in the lexicon of imagenet and
so they end up back in the toolkit
category so at bonsai we begin thinking
of is there another approach is there
another way to do this and what we came
into is our idea of machine teaching
machine teaching being sort of a
complement of machine learning and
machine learning you're often focused on
describing the details of a student of a
learning system and how that system
learns and in the underlying algorithm
the underlying mechanics of how it gets
learned and we give we often give right
now short shrift to the part that is
with the data now obviously there's a
lot of cleaning work that's done but at
the end of the day we're usually
throwing data at the algorithm and then
hoping it learns basically testing it to
see if it learns and then adjusting the
data with machine teaching the process
is about formalizing that can we instead
shift the thinking around from
programming the details of the learner
to instead programming the teacher to
staging the way things get knowledge is
shared and in this core idea machine
teaching it forms the basis for our
framework and the way it works now with
relation with databases the core idea
was around relational algebra it's like
what are the entities in this database
what are the relationships between them
it raises the interesting question and
machine teaching what is the what is the
approach what are the core ideas and so
we've identified several core ideas that
we believe form form a basis to it to a
new approach one is the idea of concepts
what is it that I want the computer to
learn and what are the relationships
between between those concepts to make
an appeal here for a moment to the game
of baseball if I were to take my
daughter and I were to teach her to play
baseball I wouldn't start by setting her
there and she's two almost three so
she's still young for all this but I
wouldn't set her there and I'd throw a
bunch of fast balls at her right I would
actually stay
yes as amusing as that might be to some
but the I would just change the process
right I would start I put the ball maybe
on a tee and we'd start with a wiffle
ball on a bad and then I have it pop up
etc etc and I know this is an intuitive
appeal but it's very interesting right
now that when we program with machine
learning our AI systems we tend to
program that way we tend to throw all
the data at it and figure out what will
go on but as I'll show you here in a
moment if we if we staged that if we
tear that we can actually get different
results out of the model so so for each
concept in our system we have a
curriculum and the curriculum is about
ok well the concept is what you want to
teach the curriculum is how you how you
teach that what is the lesson plan to
follow to to ease acquisition and
mastery and along with these curriculums
there's an lessons there they're tied to
what we call training sources and in our
system something that's interesting is
that we we support multiple kinds of
training data so this tabular data on
the right is something we're used to but
if you think of say teaching people
synthetic data is is incredibly useful
so if you you think when you're a kid
when you learn when you learned to read
time you didn't necessarily learn from
okay let's wait 10 minutes and see what
the clock says from real-world data
instead you could generate lots of data
instances and those were instructive
likewise simulations and I'll show you
what our product a lot of the focus is
on reinforcement learning so we have a
lot a lot of simulations in our system
simulations that kind of synthetic data
can help and really ideally right we can
weave these two different data types
together when we don't have data we can
use some synthetic synthetic data to
bootstrap ourselves into the position we
want to be in and then train on the real
data once we once we have a basic model
working so let's actually take a look
here at
our product so this is I'm going to show
you a few different interfaces here that
we we've built and we're playing with to
give you an idea of what we do so we
have these things called brains they're
basically models and I can create a new
one in this case I'm going to have the
AI play an open a video game it's sort
of a hello world of reinforcement
learning it's a game called cart Pole so
think of a Segway scooter there's a pole
on a cart and the cart wants to balance
the pole so it stays so it stays on top
so like this I can create a brain and
our web application right now does let
you train on the server because I want
folks to be able to see the simulation
I'm going to go ahead and and pull this
down onto my local machine
so this this main file here I'll get
into in a second this is a this is the
intelligence behind this this corporal
game hey let me let me actually start it
up for you so you can get an idea of
what we're talking about
[Music]
let that start up and get running
there we go that's it trying trying to
learn there for a second
so carpol there's not really a lot of
concepts behind this in this particular
system there's one there's balance and
we're going to take data that comes from
the simulation we're going to learn to
balance this pole and a control action
that balances this pole and we're going
to feed that to output in our
programming language here you can see
that it's typed so we have these schemas
these types are very interesting in our
language we have a type language which
is unusual these days I think largely
because it provides a hint one of
several hints that we use to decide what
kind of learning architecture to lay out
knowing the range of the types and the
types of values that expects the mean of
the program is actually really down here
it's in these these bottom lines what
has the concept and what we're saying
here is hey there's a concept I want to
teach you how to balance something
you're going to classify this it's going
to be a control action the action is is
up here this is a weird thing or an
interesting feature here the of the of
the system that this type here basically
saying I only wanted 0 I want you to
encode this as an 8-bit int but I want
you to know that a 0 either encode
either enter a 0 or a 1
so go left or go right for controlling
the cart we have some other interesting
data types like luminance that's part of
that hitting system for having a system
learned using computer vision this one
concept here basically takes that data
from input learn something and sends it
to output when we declare a concept we
have to declare a lesson and so this
lesson actually plays the carpol Python
game that from opening a gym maximizing
a specific reward function that's that's
in that gym so you can see over here
starting to begin to learn we have
several visualization systems and the
product that are kind of interesting
this one tracks the learning of the
accuracy of the system cumulative reward
over time this actually keeps track of
the signals that are coming to and from
the control system over time this is
part of investment we're generally
making and trying to make the system's
we
forcement learning systems more
debuggable I'm going to leave
reinforcement learning real quick so
while that's our primary focus we have
we started off with prototypes with with
M nest sort of the true hello world of
deep learning and so through that I can
sort of explore some some interesting
features so in that case we had one
concept but you could actually think
well what about what about M nests is
that is there something there where
multi concepts would help and the answer
is M missus so solved no it doesn't help
however there's a data set called not M
nest which is this one recognize that
this is an a right where the the
state-of-the-art algorithms don't do so
well and to make this more interesting
we actually took these letters and we we
translated them rotated them and scale
them so we basically built what CAPTCHA
for the system to solve and one of the
things we find so you'll give it this
program and in this program what I'm
basically saying is hey look I think
you'd have a better chance at guessing
what that character is if first you
think about how much it's rotated how
much it's scaled and how much it's
translated so these are basically
learned features you can think of them
like learn learn features in a pipeline
and in our system this will lay out a
network that looks like this under the
hood we use tensorflow for basically all
the algorithms and so we can use tensor
board and this kind of looks like
compiler output it's like a bunch of
deep learning algorithms laid out under
it and sure enough with this approach
you can you can beat the default
approach if you were just using user on
it that intuitively make sense right
because we're using features here now
this problem gets or I guess the first
thing to share is there's other
interesting things you can do in our
system so I talked about these learn
nodes these concepts we also have done
work to support more deterministic sort
of calculations we have the stream
statements here where you can use a
sequel like syntax you can use link to
change or or mutate the data in the data
stream what
a feature called gears that allows you
to directly import Python models and use
those as nodes or concepts in this
endless stream of data but the problem
starts to get really interesting in my
opinion when we start to deal with
behavior so let me show you this is this
is lunar lander and in this particular
model what I'm saying is I think the
system would behave more intelligently
if first it learned how to stay stable
and learned how to go to a point and
then after that it learned how to land
and you can see that for each of these
concepts here that are in the code you
also have to author specific lessons
with each of their own objective
function in this particular case in
Python I coded the objectives so you
know what is being stable being stable
is not not rotating left or right and so
you're rewarding on its ability to hold
it at a specific angle and I can give
you a video clip here of what that looks
like so here is the behavior when
untrained you can see it's sort of
floundering all over the place here is
the behavior for just stay stable no
notice it's not like landing yet that's
what we actually wanted to do but what
it is doing is it's holding a it's
holding a position in in space a
rotation in space this one is trained
for go to center so you can see here
flying to a point it's up at the top of
the screen because the reward is not
saying you know goal and yet and finally
we can composite these together into a
single land operation which is pretty
neat so there you go now the this also
reduces scopes so so if you try to go
solve this with DD PG it'll take a
hundred some 1,000 iterations or
episodes rather solve we can do it in m
10,000 a little under 10,000 using this
approach the there's another interesting
thing here though so let's go back to
that graph for a second so I talked
about
a couple important capabilities that was
a benefit of abstraction so one of those
benefits is explained ability and what's
interesting here is that you can see
sort of a given it now that I've given
the system a conceptual hierarchy for
thinking about the problem I also have
the ability to ask questions so for
example for each frame that you're
getting them this game can you tell me
back what you were thinking in that
moment so basically could you give me
back the outputs for these antecedent
gnarl networks and so you can see
actually here where the another problem
we have a name so for the process of
compositing these behaviors that's a
learn process so basically the system
can say for every frame of state what is
the correct set of behavior to compose
we call that process selection and
synthesis and we can actually graph that
in the window here where this is
representing how much attention is being
given to those different behaviors those
different skills as the system as a
system learn learns tool and the other
interesting property of this and this is
not yet implemented our system is that
these become reusable blocks or reusable
units so some of those may be like
landing aren't only useful for one
specific activity but you could imagine
things like going to X Y or staying
stable to be generally useful something
that you could reuse and so training
time our goal is to make it to the
training time invested in any one of
those blocks becomes a reasonable
component that you can use over and over
and over again within an application let
me see okay
I'll go back to here so as you can see
from from the the way the system is
today the our focus really is applying
reinforcement learning to problems we
found particular resonance with that
approach with with what we call
industrial AI so our largest customer
with our largest customer Siemens we
work on certain cyber physical systems
related to manufacturing for controlling
and optimizing their use we're also
working on problems in supply chain
management predictive maintenance things
like this related to industrial AI we
have an early access program so you can
you can come and sign up on and and
check us out so that was a super quick
tour but I wanted to open it up to
questions if anyone has questions I'll
have a mic up at the front here and you
can just come up and ask your question
Hakeem